hey guys justin here from San Diego
Comic Con 2014 we're in the Xbox lounge
and I'm talking with Marcus Smith the
creative director behind insomniac games
and the project you guys have right now
is sunset overdrive or sending behind
your big booth here what is sunset
overdrive you're gonna give me the
elevator pitch for that game what is it
so sometimes I overdrive is a game where
the end times is actually a new
beginning where you kind of have a
humdrum life but in when everything all
the rules go away you can do all the
things you've always wanted to do you
can play your music loud blow stuff up
shoot crazy weapons and and basically
you're a hero who can be who you want to
be and I've seen a lot of the game so
far it's really colorful and really
bright and a lot of people are walking
around the convention floor with this
really crazy kind of pollutant thing
what what is this guy so the story of
sunset overdrive there's a multinational
corporation called physco and fisco owns
everything they have this energy drink
called overcharge that's coming out
unfortunately there's a few side effects
it turns everybody into mutants now
fizzy here the balloon is the corporate
mascot and he is he is dedicated to the
franchise I'll put it that way um and
one of the big things about this game is
the ability to really customize your
character and make them what you want to
be and I was at a panel yesterday where
they mentioned a kangaroo codpiece as
the only thing I character is wearing
what are some of the more ridiculous
things you can make your character where
in this game I mean we have a we have a
ton of stuff we have a lot of crazy
hairstyles like i mentioned it in the
video but i love that crazy 80s hair
styles because it's not something I
would ever be able to wear but
everything has physics on it so when you
move around 80s hair-metal hair like
happens to fly around in a really crazy
way kangaroo codpiece is definitely one
of the weirder ones but there's a
there's a ton of stuff you can you can
customize yourself to be pretty insane
and people here on the show floor at
comic-con they're not going to be able
to customize their character but they
are taking part and it looks like a
multiplayer eight-player arena how does
that work in the game so we have this we
have this multiplayer experience called
chaos squad players will group together
with seven other people so it's a player
and you're going to be taking on various
missions and each mission will change
every time you play
a you have vote on which mission to take
on there's consequences to your vote and
it ends in what we're showing here
tonight which is a night defense where
you're needing to protect your base from
incoming hordes now it brings all the
frenetic energy of the campaign where
you're you're jumping and grinding and
you're using crazy weapons but then
you're doing it with eight other people
and it's just pure insanity you're
looking at it you see a lot of people
running around on the ground but this is
not just a ground based game there's a
lot of aerial stuff how does that work
in this yeah it's it's actually we're
trying to get away from the hide behind
cover kind of shooter experience and
really try to motivate people to get up
and around in the world so everything in
the environment is is bouncing ball or
grind able you can get up and slide
around on Rails it's kind of like a Tony
Hawk with guns and there's also a weapon
wheel in there I see that some of these
guys have access to a wide Wayne range
of weaponry Oh what kind of weapons do
they have to play with well you can see
right now she's using a pretty convent
or he's usually pretty conventional
weapon ak-47 but there's also that
Captain Ahab which shoots a harpoon that
shoots out over charged so it will the
monsters are addicted to the stuff so
they want it more than they want to kill
you and they'll it's a good way to
puddle it around get groups of the
enemies together we have the TN teddy
which is a teddy bear strapped at
dynamite that's a good way to mop up the
group that you've gathered together
we've got the propane which shoots
propane tanks which is another big nice
explosive weapon it's an insomniac game
so we've got a lot of crazy weapons and
you guys are gonna be at Gamescom I
assume showing off some more of the game
are we gonna see more single player or
more multiplayer over there I'm not
really sure what we're showing actually
I'm the wrong guy they're not gonna send
me I'm gonna be back in the office
trying to finish this game are you
getting to check out anything at
comic-con yourself getting to see any
this fun stuff are you stuck showing the
game all day I'm pretty much stuck
showing the game all day I'd love to go
out and see everything but but I'm I got
a job to do well it's very cool i love
the colorful action in this game it's
just that style is really distinctive I
mean you look at this you see a kangaroo
kompy's I think sunset overdrive what
what is something else that you want
people to look at you you want this to
stand out what's the thing that you make
you feel like makes the game really
stand out from every
they're shooter and game out there I
mean I think the world itself just it
isn't so colourful it's the anti end
times game it really is we you know
coming out of resistance 3 which we
loved working on it was kind of like
let's not have rubble and monochromatic
environments let's go bright and
exciting and build a world that you want
to be in and you want to spend time and
you want to go explore so it yeah I'd
say the world itself is pretty it's
pretty it is a very pretty world and if
you're here at same you comic-con you
can come by the xbox lounge and try it
out yourself and the game is coming out
not too far away from now october twenty
eighth yeah right around the corner some
october 20th you'll get to buy the game
yourself um so thanks for for watching
it if you want to get more comic con
news stay tuned